the u.s army will release a long-awaited
report today
after investigating the command culture
at fort hood texas
the investigation was launched after the
murder of 20-year-old army specialist
vanessa guillen that was back in april
her death was one of the la one of one
of at least 25 this year
was all connected to the same army post
maria villarreal is at fort hood
maria good morning to you i remember
this story so well it's just
heartbreaking what do we expect
these findings to show
good morning cbs news can confirm the
army will
fire or suspend a large number of
officers
and enlisted soldiers here at fort hood
and what the pentagon is saying
is an unprecedented disciplinary action
the 140-page report will outline what
went wrong here at fort hood and within
the army as a whole
and it will also give around 70
different recommendations
on what the army can do to rebuild trust
with its soldiers
in a one-on-one interview with cbs
evening news anchor nora o'donnell
army secretary ryan mccarthy admitted
the army has failed to keep its soldiers
safe
especially from sexual harassment and
assault
so you ordered this review yes in part
because of what happened to vanessa
again
in part yes i wanted a fresh pair of
eyes to help us
understand the problem and fix it what
surprised you just the scale
and the concern about retaliation the
high numbers
of individuals that were concerned about
reporting because in fear of retaliation
from someone in an echelon above them
people don't feel like it's safe the
individuals those in particular yes
he says he's committed to change and
last month he promised accountability
and transparency within the ranks
leaders regardless of rank are
accountable for what happens in their
units
and must have the courage to speak up
and intervene
we want justice for vanessa today's
report is expected to propose an
action plan to fix the growing problems
with leadership at fort hood
with reassignment and termination part
of that plan
those problems were magnified by
specialist vanessa gian's murder
her body was found miles off base months
after she disappeared
we spoke exclusively to vanessa's sister
myra after this investigation was
commissioned this summer
do you feel like the soldiers on that
base are safe
i don't um it's one too many
either it's accidents or they claim to
be accidents
you know we don't really know the truth
different murders
outside inside the base and um
you know at this point i i don't feel
that
anyone is safe in there before her death
gehan told her family and friends she
had been sexually harassed
on base the army says it has no evidence
of an assault but an investigation into
her death is still ongoing
gehan's death launched a movement
worldwide thousands of former military
members shared their stories with the
hashtag i am vanessa guillen
that rally and cry also led to
legislative action
in september congress introduced the i
am vanessa guillen act
to change how the military handles
sexual assault within its ranks
but gian's family is not confident this
report
will provide them with any closure
natalie kawam is their attorney because
we can't ask
you know the wolf to guard the hen house
we can't ask them to
fix themselves we need to step up as
civilians
as the world together and do this for
them because
you know our military they're people too
and they need us
guam tells us the i am vanessa gui and
bill has stalled out in congress but
they are hoping to get a hearing for it
sometime
in the new year meanwhile contacts here
at the army tell us
they are already starting to implement
change and one of them is an overhaul
of the sexual assault and reporting
program here called
sharp more to come from fort hood later
today